we're at CES 2012 i'm at the digital
experience and this is the Fitbit ultra
so you might already be familiar with
this this is an activity tracker and it
can tell you how many miles you've
crossed how many steps you've take this
year the ultra also has been updated to
tell you how many stairs you've climbed
so it's actually a very encouraging
device to get you to climb more stairs
but there's much more to Fitbit this
year this is what's new for 2012 it's
the Wi-Fi Aria smart scale and so you
could step on the scale it'll tell you
how much you weigh but it will also send
your weight via Wi-Fi to your computer
or to an app and it could also tell you
your body mass index and it can tell you
how much fat you've gained or lost over
time and so along with the activity
tracker it's sort of a complete fitness
system that will encourage you to get
out there and to lose weight and to be
more healthy this will be shipping in
April for about one hundred and thirty
dollars